επιδράσεις πολύ πολύ μεγαλύτερες από αυτές που εντοσέως σενάρια και η επιδράσεις τότε σε οικονομικών
επίβεδο μιλού για σενάρια σενάρια τοδεν μπορώ εμπρομε να πομε μιλού γι σενάρια μείωσης πληθορισμού
εφτάεις γατόνας ουμε πεντε με φτά πορεί και περισσότερο ανάλογα με το ενδιεύρηση μιλούμε για
σενάρια μείωσης τις ανάπτυξης ακόμα καιρισέσον στην ευροζόνη μιλούμε σίγουρα για και για άλλες επιτράσες
οιμόνο οικονομικές μιλούμε για τρομοκρατία το οποίον ένα σοβαρών ζήτημα ενεργειακή εαι πάρκεια και είνεργιακή
δυνατότητες τις ευροζόνης γενικότερα μιλομε για θέματα ασφάλειας τα οποία μπορεί να μας οδηγήσουν είμαστε
πα τοσύνωρον όπως μίας είμαστε τοσυν οριακόν κράτος τον του πολέμου γι την ευρώποι είμαστ
το και ίδη στη χώρα μας είναμεναι σύληψη ματομου για τρομοκρατία στην ελλάδαι οποία είναι
πρέπε να δημοσιοποιήθει τάξδήμοσε οπιθηκε πλεονέ και κάμε στοναιναιθέμα όμως τον αμέτημο σεοποιηθεί γινά δημοσοποιηθηκάμε
και ον κόσμο να νιώσικα πως ιο ήρεμος ότι οι κυπριακές αρχες κάνουν τη δούκι
να τους όπως πρέπει ναι νιώθο ότιοχείριεσμός δημοσιοποιηση οδοχερισμός ο οποίος ε κατέληξερα που είναι
ξέρω πως εκατεληες σε δημοσιοποιήσυ τον το γεγονάτο υνελάθοςο αλλάσε κάθε περίαση ας τοβάλουμε στη
στην πάντα τεωρίιότι είναι εχώ κατααβαν ότι ν αναγκιντουκόσμου να ξέρει τι γίνεται αλλά και
γόντος πιεγώ θέλω να ξέρω αλλά για ωρισμένα θέματα λα λείς ντάξει έμαθαμετούν το πράγνα
επρέπει να μάθουμε πραγν κοήθιο και ο ψήσεις ως να θέλες ναμάθεις γι νιώσεις ζωήσια
σε μια ασφαλή χώρα να ότι πορούμε να προλάβουετιςς κάστάσις ι φτάνουμε στο τέλος να
συρωισού θεωρούσει ότι κυβέρνηση